Десять місяців убивств та руйнувань в Україні.
А разом з цим і руйнування європейської віри в те,
що жодна велика сухопутна війна ніколи більше не буде вестися на їхньому континенті.
Але найважливіше те, що Європа недооцінила Володимира Путіна.
Я боюся, що, здається, Путін готовий, як я вже сказала,
потягнути за собою Росію, Україну та всіх інших.
Чи готовий до цього Захід та США?
Путін поставив себе в ситуацію, коли в нього немає гідних виходів з неї.
І я думаю, що цей шантаж і погрози є єдиним інструментом, який він може використати,
щоб спробувати виплутатися з цього.
Він намагатиметься застосувати максимальну силу,
і якщо ядерна зброя є частиною цього арсеналу, а вона справді такою є,
і він відчуває, що це дасть йому перевагу, я не сумніваюся,
що ми повинні бути готові до того, що він її використає.
Ризик дозволити президенту Путіну перемогти набагато вищий,
ніж продовжувати підтримувати Україну так, як ми це робимо.
Протягом року DW описувала хід цієї війни, як це бачили дуже різні спостерігачі.
Українські, російські, європейські та американські.
Зараз у цій спеціальній програмі ми розглянемо різницю між тим, що було сказано,
і тим, що сталося, і спробуємо оцінити, як конфлікт може розвиватися в найближчі місяці.
Але давайте розпочнемо з морозної зими у Східній Європі в лютому торік,
коли десятки тисяч російських військ розташувалися за крок від українських кордонів.
Вранці 24-го вони вторглися в Україну - сейсмічний удар для всієї європейської конструкції безпеки.
Це почалося не з однієї брехні, а з хуртовини фальшивих заперечень і звинувачень щодо західної істерії.
Навіть коли сили РФ скупчилися вздовж українського кордону,
кремлівські дипломати та спостерігачі запевняли світ, що Москва нікому не загрожує.
Про війну буцімто не могло бути й мови.
На мій погляд, це зовсім малоймовірно, тому що це не на російському порядку денному.
Але це гра з високими ставками, і я абсолютно впевнений, що пан Путін, яким ми його знаємо,
а ми знаємо його вже дуже-дуже багато років, - він не азартний гравець.
Не азартний гравець - але яку інформацію отримував Путін?
За словами російських інсайдерів, російські державні службовці на всіх рівнях влади
говорили своєму начальству лише те, що від них хотіли почути - правда це чи ні.
Я вважаю, що на дуже низькому рівні люди, які дійсно працюють, так би мовити, у полях, знають правду.
Але оскільки правду повідомляють знизу вгору, вона багато в чому спотворюється.
Тож не дивно, що особи, які ухвалюють рішення на верхньому кінці ланцюжка, мають інформацію,
яка не відповідає дійсності в повній мірі.
У Росії нині не можна говорити нічого, крім того, що тобі скаже Кремль або Міністерство оборони.
Тож вони можуть вигадати будь-яку історію.
І дійсно, ви розповідали про Радянський Союз, а потім про Росію - вони завжди брехали.
Але тепер вони весь час просто брешуть крізь зуби.
Українці швидко запросили підтримку Заходу,
запровадження жорстких санкцій проти Росії та постачання зброї, щоб дати відсіч набагато більшій армії.
Той факт, що багато хто пророкував швидку перемогу Росії, здавалося, тільки посилив завзятість українців.
Вони адаптувалися до війни як частини свого повсякдення.
Я особисто навчилася з цим жити, як і мільйони українців, які залишилися в Україні.
Дивне відчуття, що, знаєте, завтра все може закінчитися.
Але я думаю, що страх втратити свободу, втратити життя у вільній Україні, втратити свою домівку - більший,
ніж страх втратити власне життя.
Коли просування Москви зупинилося на кількох фронтах,
росіяни підняли ставки погрозами про свою ядерну зброю.
І світ замислився: Путін блефує? Чи це може бути початком Третьої світової війни?
Так. Ми сприймаємо це серйозно.
Зараз ми сприймаємо це серйозно, тому що, дивіться, він має, а можливо, не має інших бойових знарядь,
щоб протистояти українським контрнаступам.
Тож я думаю, що Україна сприймає це серйозно.
І міжнародна спільнота має сприймати це серйозно.
Ви сказали, що найбільше Вас непокоїло в російському посольстві те,
як деякі з Ваших колег-дипломатів говорили про ядерні удари по Заходу,
хоча вони працювали в сфері контролю над озброєннями.
Невже вони не уявляли, що ці ядерні удари, про які вони говорили,
можуть призвести до Третьої світової війни чи до її наслідків?
Ви знаєте, це дуже небезпечно, що ті люди, які вихваляються цією можливістю
завдати ядерних ударів по Заходу, по США в першу чергу, ці люди впевнені, що ніякої відплати не буде,
що Захід просто проковтне це і просто схилить коліна і скаже:
"Добре, добре, ми боїмося. Ми боїмося. Добре, давайте вести мирні переговори".
Я вважаю, що мета цієї ядерної риторики і тих погроз, які ми бачили з боку Росії -
це, звичайно, змусити нас, шантажувати нас, щоб ми припинили підтримку України.
Але якщо ми це зробимо, то президент Путін переможе в Україні.
І якщо він переможе в Україні, це буде дуже небезпечним сигналом усім авторитарним лідерам світу,
що жорстоко застосовуючи військову силу, порушуючи міжнародне право, вони досягнуть своїх цілей.
Тож поки бої в Україні точилися, НАТО інтерпретувало цей конфлікт як битву за кожну демократичну державу.
За свободу, демократію та верховенство права.
Але чи був Альянс взагалі готовий до боротьби такого масштабу?
Я маю на увазі, що наслідком усього цього є ефективне стримування.
І я не втомлююся знову і знову наголошувати на необхідності для НАТО налаштуватися,
мобілізуватися, бути готовим до ведення війни за національне виживання своїх членів.
А це означає збройні сили такого масштабу, якого ми не бачили з найнапруженіших днів холодної війни,
з дійсно значними силами, здатними діяти.
А це означатиме переозброєння. Це означатиме перебудову сил.
Це означатиме, що це матиме наслідки для наших суспільств у спосіб, якого ми не бачили вже поколіннями.
Я думаю, що президент Путін дав НАТО нове дихання після епохи експедиційної війни.
Деякі люди в Альянсі задавалися питанням, чи це все ще актуально.
Ми весь час попереджали наших західних союзників, що російська державна ідеологія,
російські служби безпеки та російські військові маневри свідчать про новий імперіалізм.
І, на жаль, це справдилося.
НАТО знадобилися роки, щоб написати плани дій у надзвичайних ситуаціях для Центральної Європи,
і лише потім з'явилася мінімальна фізична присутність.
Але ця фізична присутність нині зростає.
Вона, може, і зростає, але в Угорщині, ще одному члені НАТО, уряд випробовує єдність Альянсу,
відмовляючись відправляти зброю в Україну чи пропускати її через свою територію.
Чи є Будапешт слабкою ланкою в ланцюзі НАТО?
НАТО хоче, щоб Зеленський виграв війну.
Ваш прем'єр називає його опонентом.
НАТО надсилає дедалі більше зброї.
Ви кажете, що це лише затягує війну. Ви хочете, щоб Зеленський виграв війну?
Ми хочемо миру.
Ви не хочете, щоб він виграв?
Чого б це не коштувало і як би це не було досягнуто…
Навіть якщо це мир на умовах Москви?
Що б не відбувалося в Україні, це недобре. Не лише для Угорщини, а й для Європи.
А як же російський народ? Важко збагнути, як росіяни насправді ставляться до війни.
А ще важче зрозуміти, чи звертає взагалі на них увагу Кремль.
Вони не хочуть про це думати. Дуже багато людей пишуть мені у коментарях на моєму Telegram-каналі:
"Ми не хочемо нічого знати. Чому ви продовжуєте нам говорити, що ми робимо злочини в Україні?
Ми не хочемо знати про це, тому що це надто важко. Це нелегко".
А ще в Росії проблеми у внутрішніх стосунках у родинах.
Люди воюють між собою. Вони розлучаються.
У них жахливі конфлікти з друзями, з родичами, чоловіками і дружинами, братами.
Я маю на увазі, що це дійсно неприйнятно для мільйонів росіян.
Отже, поки росіяни сперечаються між собою, політична опозиція була знищена,
її лідери здебільшого у в’язниці або втекли з країни.
Тому якщо і з'явиться загроза лідерству Путіна, то не від когось із них.
Що б не трапилося з Путіним, немає жодних ознак того, що якась ліберальна фракція
чекає свого часу, щоб перехопити владу, чи не так? Жодної?
Ні, ні, її не існує. І, чесно кажучи, якщо є надія, що зараз, скажімо, російські олігархи можуть збунтуватися
лише через те, що вони потрапили під санкції - це не варіант.
Ці люди втратили свої контракти із Заходом ще кілька років тому,
і їм надав допомогу уряд РФ військовими контрактами.
Зараз багато з них стали частиною російського військово-промислового комплексу,
і це робить їх ще більш залежними від Кремля та Путіна.
Але чи не ослабла влада Путіна?
Його армія не виправдала жодного з очікувань.
Повідомляється про десятки тисяч загиблих російських військових.
Які карти йому залишилося розіграти?
Чесно кажучи, я не зовсім розумію, як Путін може вийти з цього, не оголосивши якоїсь перемоги. Йому це потрібно.
Йому потрібно забезпечити якусь перемогу перед очима росіян і всього світу,
тому що все це стосується його статусу.
Але, чесно кажучи, я не дуже розумію, що це може бути.
Тому що навіть якщо він, скажімо, матиме якусь домовленість із Зеленським,
санкції все одно працюють. Економіка розорена. І для чого це все?
Чи зможе Путін у довгостроковій перспективі це пережити, як Ви думаєте?
Я так не думаю.
Відтоді, як ми поспілкувались із Солдатовим, Москва почувається кепсько на полі бою.
Пишні кремлівські святкування анексії виявилися абсурдно передчасними та принизливими.
Більша частина Херсонської області, яку Путін назвав "назавжди російською",
невдовзі була відвойована Україною.
Західні військові експерти бачать добрі перспективи для президента Зеленського на найближчі місяці.
Мені здається, що Україна досягла незворотного імпульсу, що Росія не може відкотити це назад.
І навіть президент Зеленський сказав, що, мовляв, мені війська не потрібні.
Мені потрібні інструменти, обладнання, амуніція тощо.
І тому я думаю, що шлях, яким ми зараз йдемо, поки Захід зберігає зґуртованість і виконує все, що обіцяв,
і надалі збирається виконувати, зберігаючи санкції,
це не обов’язково призведе до конфлікту за участю НАТО безпосередньо проти Росії.
Але ключовим буде те, щоб ми всі трималися разом.
І я оцінюю ситуацію так, що Україна звільнить Крим до кінця літа, до серпня 2023 року.
Генерал Ходжес цілком може мати рацію.
Але якщо Путін програє цю війну, то чи може він залишатися таким же небезпечним,
як і у випадку його перемоги?
Так чи інакше, здається, ніхто не вірить, що світ повернеться до того, яким був рік тому.
Я не можу собі уявити, що через кілька тижнів чи місяців після завершення цього конфлікту все стане, як було завжди.
Російська держава буде завжди. Є і, звичайно, буде. І завжди повинна бути російська держава.
І нам потрібно буде працювати з ними щодо всіх великих питань, які зараз для нас важливі.
Але я вважаю, що наголос має бути зроблений на захисті міжнародного порядку,
який включає безумовну повагу до кордонів, повагу до міжнародного права, повагу до прав людини.
Я впевнений, що після того, як ця українська воєнна криза закінчиться, світ стане зовсім іншим.
І всі попередні підходи, всі попередні концепції взаємного стримування, балансу вже не працюватимуть.
І я можу з вами погодитися, що це дуже небезпечний розвиток ситуації,
тому що існування ядерного арсеналу більше не буде ані психологічним, ані військовим бар’єром.
Попри зиму військові дії на території України продовжуються.
Росіяни атакують енергетичну інфраструктуру України
з метою збільшити страждання людей і знищити їхній моральний дух.
Україна чітко дала зрозуміти, що прагне щонайменше перемоги та повернення всіх окупованих територій.
Але Захід набагато менш конкретний і менш єдиний щодо того, що має означати перемога.
І поки ця невизначеність зберігається, доля Європи та безпека мільйонів її громадян
продовжуватимуть висіти на волосині.